the one thing that we always think about
as a leader the person that went to war
and save people's lives and encourage
them to dream and Martin Luther King
says I have a dream you oughta dream as
well Lincoln want to change the world
you know a patent or a Churchill or
Reagan or Kennedy they inspire they
inject they get people want to move they
get people want to go out there and do
something very big with our lives
inspiration they fire you up they get
you to do something you would have never
done by yourself leadership is something
that very few people actually see the
work of a leader leader is not
necessarily the stuff he's young you
know out there when everybody's
recognizing them they're getting
atrophied leadership it's really what
you do behind the scenes and a lot of
times behind-the-scenes leaders who know
the difference between leaders and
leaner you gonna come across a leader
that's gonna tell you can do it you
should go for it I think you pull this
on it's gonna be painful we should give
it a shot
what if it does take points what if you
go out there make a difference what have
you doing your dreams what if you go
gives all the odds what if you prove
everybody wrong in your office and you
can do it
a leader is striving constantly to move
up and to be the 20% to be the 1% to
move up to be the small or leader that's
taking on more responsibility from the
top to mover more leadership positions
from the top so eventually gets to the
top and the person above them says you
know what you can do a better job than I
am you take over my position because
you've been leading for such a long time
I'm proud of you this position is now
yours but it only happens to those that
have made a decision and committed to
leading not constantly leaning my
challenge to you is in every single
category of 80/20 who gets who
you'll be the leader of the 20% not a
leaner in the 80%
[Music]